THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF
HANNITY, DEMOCRATIC
SCANDALS.
I'M JEANINE PIRRO IN FOR
SEAN TONIGHT.
LIBERALS ARE REELING FROM A
RAVE OF CALAMITIES THAT
COULD HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES.
REPUBLICANS ARE CALLING FOR
A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE THE FBI'S
HANDLING OF THE CLINTON
EMAIL PROBE.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES
CONTINUES TO EXPOSE SEVERE
FISA ABUSES AND FORMER OBAMA
OFFICIALS ARE FACING NEW
SCRUTINY.
BUT, FIRST, TONIGHT, WE
START WITH THE MAJOR BATTLE
RAGING BETWEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LIBERAL STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
NOW LOOKING INTO A POSSIBLE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
CHARGE AGAINST THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND.
THIS COMES AFTER THE MAYOR
ALERT YOU HAD ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
BAY AREA THAT FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES WERE
PREPARING TO CONDUCT RAIDS.
THE ACTING ICE DIRECTOR IS
OAKLAND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT SHE DID IS NO BETTER
THAN, YOU KNOW, A GANG
LOOKOUT YELLING POLICE.
WHEN A POLICE CRUISER COMES
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD, EXCEPT
SHE DID IT TO THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY.
I MEAN, IT'S BEYOND THE
PALE.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
34 YEARS.
THIS IS A WHOLE NEW LOW TO
INTENTIONALLY WARN CRIMINALS
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
COMING.
BEING A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IS ALREADY DANGEROUS
ENOUGH.
BUT TO GIVE THE CRIMINALS A
HEADS UP THAT WE'RE COMING
IN THE NEXT 24 HOURS,
INCREASES THAT RISK.
PUTS -- YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THESE ARE AMERICAN
HEROES.
STRAP A GUN TO THE HIP EVERY
DAY TO DEFEND THIS NATION.
AND TO TELL THE CRIMINALS WE
ARE COMING IN THE NEXT 24
HOURS IS JUST INCREDIBLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE HEAD
OF ICE IS ALSO SAYING
BECAUSE OF THE MAYOR'S
WARNING ABOUT 800 CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ESCAPED
THE ARRESTS.
STILL ABLE TO DETAIN 232
SUSPECTED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IN FOUR-DAY RAID.
ACCORDING TO ICE, 115 OF THE
PEOPLE ARRESTED HAD, QUOTE,
PRIOR FELONY CONVICTIONS FOR
SERIOUS FOR SERIOUS VIOLENT
OFFENSES.
DESPITE THESE FACTS THE
MAYOR OF OAKLAND IS ACTUALLY
DEFENDING HER DECISION TO
PROTECT AND SHIELD ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
HERE'S WHAT THE MAYOR WROTE
ON TWITTER.
I DO NOT REGRET SHARING THIS
INFORMATION.
IT IS OAKLAND'S LEGAL RIGHT
TO BE A SANCTUARY CITY AND
WE HAVE NOT BROKEN ANY LAWS.
WE BELIEVE OUR COMMUNITY IS
SAFER WHEN FAMILIES SAY STAY
TOGETHER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO APPEARS
TO BE FED UP WITH CALIFORNIA
SANCTUARY POLICIES.
HE RECENTLY THREATENED TO
PULL ICE AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS FROM THE STATE
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
REFUSING TO COOPERATE WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE GETTING NO HELP
FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FRANKLY, IF I WANTED TO PULL
OUR PEOPLE FROM CALIFORNIA,
YOU WOULD HAVE A CRIME NEST
LIKE YOU HAD EVER SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALL I WOULD HAVE TO SAY IS
ICE AND BORDER PATROL.
LET CALIFORNIA ALONE, YOU
YOU WOULD WOULD BE INUNDATED
AND SEE CRIME LIKE NOBODY
HAS EVER SEEN CRIME IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YET, WE GET NO HELP FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE NOW
WITH REACTION FROM THE
CENTER FOR IMMIGRATION
STUDIES JESSICA VAUGHN,
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY
FRANCISCO HERNANDEZ AND
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO
THE PRESIDENT AND FOX NEWS
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GORKA.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, ALL.
I'M GOING TO START WITH YOU,
JESSICA.
>> THANK YOU, YOUR HONOR.
>> Judge Jeanine: IS IT A
PROTECTION OF CITIZENS TO
PREVENT ICE AGENTS FROM
DOING THEIR JOB FOR WHICH
THEY HAVE LEGAL AUTHORITY?
>> WELL, NO.
CITIZENS WANT OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS ENFORCED.
AND ISIS TARGETS, AS YOU
MENTIONED ARE FELONS.
CRIMINALS, GANG MEMBERS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED BEFORE.
IMMIGRATION VIOLATERS
MULTIPLE TIMES.
AND THEY WERE GOING AFTER
THE CRIMINALS.
ICE WOULD MUCH RATHER ARREST
THEM IN THE JAILS BUT CITIES
LIKE OAKLAND PREVENT ICE
FROM DOING THAT.
THEY TELL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THEY
CAN'T COOPERATE AND THAT'S
WHY THESE CRIMINALS ARE ON
THE STREET TO BEGIN WITH.
BECAUSE ICE WOULD HAVE
ARRESTED THEM EARLIER IF
THEY COULD.
AND NOW THEY HAVE GOT TO GO
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY TO DO
SO AND.
>> Judge Jeanine: SO IT'S
MORE DANGEROUS.
SO IT'S MORE DANGEROUS FOR
EVERYONE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, FRANCISCO
HERNANDEZ, YOU ARE AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
>> YES.
>> WHEN THE OAKLAND'S MAYOR
SAYS WE BELIEVE OUR
COMMUNITY IS SAFER WHEN
FAMILIES STAY TOGETHER, DOES
KATE STEINLE AND HER ABILITY
NOW THAT SHE IS 6 FEET UNDER
TO STAY WITH HER FAMILY,
DOES THAT ENTER INTO THE
MAYOR'S MIND AT ALL?
>> WELL, IT CAN'T.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
SANCTUARY CITY IS A
POLITICAL PHANTOM, YOUR
HONOR.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: NO, I
DON'T.
>> NO CITY OR COUNTY CAN
OPPOSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
YOU ARE TELLING ME THAT ICE
CAN CATCH 800 PEOPLE AT THE
SAME TIME BUT THEY ARE
SNICHESD OUT BY A MAYOR?
I MEAN WHAT KIND OF SECRET
WAS IT?
AND WHY HAVEN'T THEY PICKED
THEM UP BEFORE?
THEY HAVE BEEN DEPORTED
BEFORE AND THEY WERE IN THE
JAIL.
WHY DIDN'T THEY HOLD THEM
THEN?
GUYS, THIS IS -- YOU KNOW
WHAT?
WE WERE ON THE CUSP OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
WE THOUGHT EVERYONE WAS ON
THE SAME PAGE BUT THE
SHOOTING IN FLORIDA, OKAY,
NOW, HAVE YOU GOT THE
PRESIDENT CRAW FISHING.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
WANT TO GO INTO FLORIDA
RIGHT NOW.
DR. GORKA, LET ME ASK YOU
THIS, BECAUSE THE MAYOR SAID
SOMETHING, YOU KNOW, THAT
REALLY DOESN'T MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, JUST READ THE
MAYOR'S TWEET.
I HOPE THIS WOMAN DIDN'T
HAVE ANY LEGAL TRAINING.
SHE SAID IT'S THE CITY'S
RIGHTS.
CITIES DON'T HAVE RIGHTS.
U.S. CITIZENS HAVE RIGHTS.
AND THE CITY HAS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
THEM.
THE MAYOR OF ANY CITY HAS NO
POWER WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION.
THAT'S A USE OF WILL FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES.
SHE SAID FAMILIES HAVE TO BE
PROTECTED.
GUESS WHAT, AL CAPONE HAD A
FAMILY.
SO DID PABLO ESCABAR.
NOT ALL FAMILIES ARE GOOD.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE'S THE
PROBLEM.
AND JESSICA, I'M GOING TO GO
TO YOU ON THIS NOW.
IF FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS ARE FORCED TO INTO A
CITY WITHOUT HAVING THE
ASSISTANCE OF LOCALS OR AT
LEAST THE IDENTIFICATION OF
WHERE THESE ILLEGAL FELONS
AND REMEMBER.
>> THEY DON'T NEED IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: FRANCISCO,
WAIT A MINUTE, THE TRUTH IS
IF THEY ARE BEING HIDDEN OR
NOT AT THE ADDRESSES AND I
HAVE DONE ENOUGH WARRANTS
AND I HAVE HAD A WHOLE TEAM
OF COPS THAT WORK FOR ME.
>> YOU HAVE YOUR HONOR.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING, IS, WE ARE GOING
TO GIVE THEM A HEADS UP SO
THEY CAN NEVER BE ARRESTED.
NOW THE FEDS HAVE TO COME IN
AND GET INVOLVED IN A MIDDLE
OF A SOCIETY WHERE PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO LIVE SAFELY
WHERE IT COULD HAVE BAN
ACCOMMODATED VERY EASILY BY
THE LOCALS AND THE FEDS
WORKING TOGETHER TO ARREST A
CONVICTED FELON.
JESSICA?
>> IS THERE A QUESTION
THERE, YOUR HONOR?
>> Judge Jeanine: YEAH,
THERE IS I'M GOING TO GET TO
YOU A IN A MINUTE SO HANG
ON.
>> IN 90% OF THE COUNTRY.
ICE DOES ITS WORK OF
DEPORTING CRIMINALS BY
ARRESTING THEM IN THE JAIL.
THEY DON'T GET THAT KIND OF
COOPERATION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PARTICULARLY IN OAKLAND.
THAT'S WHY THESE CRIMINAL
ALIENS WERE ON THE STREET TO
BEGIN WITH.
>> SERIOUSLY?
>> ICE DOES DEPEND ON
COOPERATION FROM STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR AN
OPERATION LIKE THIS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET SHOT
AT BY A POLICE OFFICER THAT
DOESN'T KNOW THEY'RE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD DOING THIS KIND
OF OPERATION AND PERHAPS
THAT'S WHERE THE MAYOR GOT
TIPPED OFF.
WHO KNOWS.
BUT SHE IS ALSO BASICALLY
TELLING PEOPLE TO RESIST
ARREST YOU THIS IS ABSURD
ALSO.
THIS HAS CONSEQUENCES.
>> NO.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
MAYBE HARMED.
>> Judge Jeanine: THERE IS
NO QUESTION.
>> TOOK THE MAYOR'S WARNING
LET ME GO TO FRANCISCO.
WAIT A MINUTE, FRANCISCO.
>> YES OR NO, YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE DEFINITION OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE?
>> I AM.
>> Judge Jeanine: DEFINITION
OF OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IS
WHEN SOMEONE OBSTRUCTS OR
IMPEDES THE ADMINISTRATION
OF LAW UNDER WHICH ANY
PENDING PROCEEDING IS BEING
HAD BEFORE ANY AGENCY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
TO ME, OBSTRUCTIONS OF
JUSTIFIABLE IS WHAT THIS
MAYOR SHOULD BE CHARGED
WITH.
>> IF ICE KNOWS THAT THIS
MAYOR RUNS WITH SUPPOSEDLY
IS A SANCTUARY CITY, AND THE
SECRET GETS OUT TO HER, WHAT
KIND OF A SECRET DO WE HAVE
ICE AND DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
>> MISSING THE POINT.
>> THE STATE GETS THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON'T
CARE IF SHE ASSISTS THEM.
I CARE IF SHE OBSTRUCTS
THEM.
GO AHEAD, SEBASTIAN.
>> AGAIN, YOUR GUEST ISN'T
ANSWERING THE POINT HERE.
THE MAYOR IS TREATING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AS A
PROTECTED CLASS THEY ARE NOT
PROTECTED CLASS.
THEY ARE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AND MORE THAN 150 OF THEM
SERIOUS VIOLENT.
WHEN DOES A MAYOR PROTECT
PEOPLE THAT HAVE CONVICTED
SERIOUS FELONIES.
>> IF THEY HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED WHY HAVEN'T THEY
PICKED THEM UP YET.
>> Judge Jeanine: MAYORS
LIKE THIS MAYOR IS HIDING
THEM AND ALERTING THEM.
COME ON, SAN FRANCISCO, YOU
KNOW BETTER THAN THAT AND
NOT ONLY THAT.
THE LOCALS, WAIT A MINUTE.
>> Jesse: CA.
WAIT A MINUTE, JESSICA.
PAUSE THE LOCALS ARE LETTING
THEM OUT THE SIDE DOOR WHEN
THEY KNOW ICE IS COMING.
>> IT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY GOT IMMIGRATION.
>> FEDS CANNOT PROTECT
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> YOUR HONOR, YOUR HONOR,
YOU KNOW THAT IS A LIE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I KNOW
WHAT I KNOW.
DON'T TELL ME WHAT I KNOW IT
IS TRUE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> Judge Jeanine: DON'T COME
ON THIS SHOW AND TELL ME
WHAT IS TRUE AND WHAT ISN'T
TRUE.
GO AHEAD, JESSICA.
>> IT'S NOT TRUE.
IT'S A LIE.
>> OAKLAND, SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
COOPERATE WITH ICE.
THEY RELEASE CRIMINAL ALIENS
THAT ICE HAS IDENTIFIED
THROUGH BIOMETRICS
DEPORTABLE FROM THE COUNTRY
BUT THEY REFUSE TO ALLOW ICE
TO COME AND PICK UP THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ON TO
BEGIN WITH.
>> ABSOLUTELY A LIE.
>> WHY IS THAT A LIE?
>> IT WAS FEDERAL POLICY.
CATCH AND RELEASE.
>> YOU ARE TELLING ME THE
CITY DID K. DISABLE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
A CITY JAIL CAN DISABLE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND KEEP
THEM FROM PICKING SOMEBODY
UP.
THEY DO IT EVERY DAY.
DRUG DEALERS, DRUG
TRAFFICKERS THEY DO IT
EVERYDAY.
>> Judge Jeanine: I USED TO
SEND MY GUYS OUT ALL THE
TIME TO MAKE ARRESTS.
WE WOULD BREAK THROUGH THE
DOORS AT 45:00 IN THE
MORNING.
IF THEY AREN'T THERE BECAUSE
THEY GOT A TIP THEN I CAN'T
ARREST THEM.
>> FOR PRESIDENT.
>> UNDER OBAMA, IT WAS
FEDERAL POLICY FROM THE TOP
DOWN.
CATCH AND RELEASE.
EVEN AT THE BORDER AND
ENCOURAGING THE CREATION OF
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE HAD FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
IT STOPPED ON JANUARY THE
20TH.
THESE PEOPLE ARE AIDING AND
ABETTING CRIMINALS.
>> DID YOU FORGET THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA DEPORTED
2.5 MILLION.
>> THAT'S FALLACIOUS.
>> Judge Jeanine: LAST
QUESTION TO YOU, WHEN THE
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN SAYS WE
PROTECT ALL OF OUR PEOPLE
FROM CRIMINALS, AND WE
DEFEND EVERYONE WHO COMES
HERE FOR A BETTER LIFE.
>> DID NOT SAY THAT.
>> SHE DID SAY THAT JERRY
BROWN.
>> DID NOT.
>> Judge Jeanine: WOW.
>> OBVIOUSLY THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA NEED SOME
SANCTUARY FROM THEIR
LEGISLATURE AND THEIR
GOVERNOR AND FROM MAYORS
LIKE THIS BECAUSE THEY ARE
CREATING PUBLIC SAFETY
HAZARD BY RELEASING CRIMINAL
ALIENS EVERY SINGLE DAY WHO
GO OUT AND PREY AGAIN ON
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY.
>> CALIFORNIA HAS TRUMPED
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: YEAH,
THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY HAVE.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT NOW, WHAT
DO YOU SAY IF THE PRESIDENT
DOES WHAT HE THREATENED TO
DO AND THAT IS TAKE ALL THE
ICE AGENTS OUT AND THEN YOU
GUYS CAN DEAL WITH THEM
UNTIL YOU BEG FOR THE ICE
AGENTS TO COME BACK.
>> YEAH.
WELL, THAT'S GENIUS.
THAT'S PURE GENIUS.
HAVE YOU ALL NOT FIGURED OUT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
NEW YORK LIBERAL?
FROM NEW YORK.
HE HAS NEVER EVEN LIVED IN
CALIFORNIA.
I MEAN, COME ON.
>> 8% DROP IN ILLEGAL
MIGRATION SOUTHERN BORDER
SINCE HE WAS INAUGURATED.
RIGHT.
>> NOTHING TO DO WITH, YOU
KNOW, IMMIGRATION IS AN
ISSUE THAT CROSSES
TRADITIONAL PARTY LINES.
THIS IS -- THIS IS A MATTER
OF CALIFORNIA POLITICIANS
NOT BEING HAPPY WITH
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
WANTING TO CREATE A NEW
ELECTORATE FOR THEMSELVES.
>> BINGO.
>> THAT'S WHAT THIS BOILS
DOWN TO.
>> Judge Jeanine: ALL ABOUT
DEMOGRAPHICS.
ALL RIGHT.
IN RESPONSE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN TOLD
CNBC AND CALIFORNIA WE
PROTECT ALL OUR PEOPLE FROM
CRIMINALS AND IN THE STATE
OF THE STATE THE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR ISSUED A STRONG WE
BUICK.
SO THERE HAVE YOU IT FOR
SAYING HE NEVER SAID IT.
NOW, I'M GOING TO END.
>> HE DIDN'T.
SHOW ME THE QUOTE.
>> Judge Jeanine: COME ON.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY, 30 SECONDS,
TELL ME WHY WHAT THE ICE
AGENTS ARE DOING SHOULD BE
BLOCKED BY LOCAL POLITICIANS
IN CALIFORNIA.
>> ICE DOES NOT NEED THE
ASSISTANCE OF CITIES, STATES
OR COUNTIES.
CAN I DO THE JOB.
LET THE TROOPS DO WHAT THEY
DO.
THE TROOPS KNOW WHAT THEY
THE PROBLEM IS WITH POLITICS
AND YOU GOT EVERYBODY CRAW
FISHING.
WE WERE ON THE CUSP OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM DECIDING
THOUGH GETS TO STAY AND WHO
GETS TO GOVERNMENT.
NOW, NOBODY WANTS TO TOUCH
IT BECAUSE WE HAVE GOT THE
GUN ISSUE.
EVERYBODY IS CRAW FISHING.
BOTH SIDES.
>> WAIT A MINUTE, ARE YOU
TELLING ME ALL OF THE SUDDEN
THE LIBERALS COULD CARE LESS
ABOUT THE DREAMERS BECAUSE
THEY WERE MORE WORRIED ABOUT
GUNS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID I WILL
GIVE 1.8 MILLION PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
TRIPLE WHAT OBAMA DID.
NOW YOU WANT TO SAY THAT
TRUMP DIDN'T DO HIS JOB?
YOU ANSWER.
>> I'M IN I TOLD MR. HANNITY
DO IT.
>> YOUR GUEST WAS ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THIS AS A
MAYOR?
THERE IS ONE REASON.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND THEY WANT
TO HAVE NEW VOTERS MADE OUT
OF THESE ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THAT'S THE END OF THE
MESSAGE.
WE WANT TO CREATE A NEW
VOTING BLOCK.
IT'S NOTHING TO DO WITH
SAFETY.
IT'S POLITICS AND IT IS A.
>> THEY CAN'T VOTE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THEY CAN'T
VOTE?
>> WATCH MY SHOW TOMORROW